hey guys it's evan caitlin podcast the
podcast currently being made by zombies
our caitlin zombie instincts aren't on
point you did not run as fast as I was
expecting
well you know if I run this way I'd hit
a wall you have open space so so there's
that if you guys didn't get the hint
from the wonderful opening intro we're
gonna be talking about the zombie
apocalypse today yeah because we just
finished our zombie weapon yeah and and
zombies are I don't know why is Ami's
are such a fun topic to talk about or
they catch the public interest so much
do you have any theories Katelyn um I
don't know I think like apocalypse in
general is just fascinating yeah yeah
there's a lot of movies a lot of TV
shows and books and games about zombies
in the end of the world and everything
baby that says something about humans
anyways that's pretty much the whole
outline of course we are going to be
doing the thing that the week in the
wrap-up we are gonna try to keep I think
that like it's a new venture of ours to
just like to use punch or Mike be very
efficient with podcasting who also guys
exciting thing today's episode is
sponsored by Squarespace
yeah thanks guys we'll see be saying
more about them later in the episode
look at so good thank you
Kalyn did all of the research prep for
this podcast so I'm gonna let you like
take it away wait I have an update you
have an update yeah and it's gonna make
me not very good at surviving a zombie
apocalypse oh yeah I think I might have
broken my toe mm-hmm that's very sad I
know it wasn't even so unexpected - and
it wasn't even with the zombie weapon
like my thought one of us was gonna get
at least lightly injured using that
weapon yeah cuz it's very spiky and
sharp but then we're just moving some
two by fours around we're working on our
attic projects and one fell on my foot
and it was like such a such a non-event
- I felt really bad it look like I
really heard it's so strange because it
was just like a 2x4 and it wasn't you
ty4 30 30 inches less than three feet
long and it is always like leaning
upright and then it is fell to the side
yeah and it just happened to hit your
toe at just the wrong angle or something
just the wrong point no do you need to
start taking calcium supplements I've
never broken anything before ever well I
don't know it's broken right this is not
confirmed oh you looked at it and you
almost pass out my toe hurts and you
showed me like oh yeah that looks pretty
bad looks like a really bad bruise or
something I mean we kept working like we
were in the Attic for like two hours
after that yeah and then and it hurt but
I mean like you know it didn't look that
bad
no it looks bad and it still hurt I
don't know if it's broken I texted
pictures to my parents and they're like
just tape it next to the other toe okay
that's all you can do really is broken
that's all you can like this in case
your whole foot in a cast that would be
terrible
how do you terrible really stink Oh like
you know pass stink in general but like
a foot casts are probably the worst
thing have you ever had a cast why do I
have to think about it I don't remember
ever having a cast I'll ask my mom later
no I don't think I did though my brother
broke a bone when he was doing Taekwondo
once um but I think that's only broken
bone in our family yeah I've never had a
cast yeah I don't think any of my mom's
like it's so strange because like you
had like a five to four pound board hit
your toe and I I had like eight the
700-pound motor drop on my whole foot
but yeah but you had steel toes on but
it felt like oh well because I didn't
bring my toes but it felt like on the
arch knife
that's true I did yeah it didn't even
follow my toes at all just like bounced
off my foot yeah Samba apocalypse we are
now prepared we have our wet main weapon
of choice now what's interesting is like
we wanted to make this particular weapon
because it'd be like fun and interesting
and dislike and if you haven't seen the
video yet the weapon is a flail
it's a flail and it's on a very long
pole like a metal pole we got all the
materials from the hardware store
there's a chain on the end of the pole
and then the ball we made out of washers
and screws so we welded a bunch of
washers together so if they form like a
hollow metal ball and then we ground
down screws to make them extra point D
and then we welded those on to the ball
it's completely deadly it's a deadly
weapon 100% sure if you swung that out
of someone like that's it's a lethal
weapon it's it's it's a bit scary and
oppressive yeah I mean we destroyed a
bunch of fruit and a table yes by you
know I think that if I were to make like
if I was gonna make like an actual
zombie weapon I would remove the chain
and just like screw the ball that we
made onto the long pipe I actually think
so too because the chain like it makes
it unpredictable yeah it makes them
predictable it introduces a certain
level of chaos yeah and that's not
exactly what you're going but I do think
having the spiky ball on the end of the
pipe is better than like having an
intense or atmosphere because like no
matter what angle you it's like
omnidirectional yes omnidirectional II
dangerous now what I might want to do
and and this might be a project idea for
later I've actually thought of this like
go back revisit this weapon weld on a
like attachment point for the pipe so
then like the ball can either be on a
chain or it can be attached directly and
then we make a knife that can be screwed
on with the same pipe so they'll be like
dual sided weapon and one side will be
knife and on one side it'll be a ball so
it's like the knife is for stabbing yeah
and the ball is for destroying yeah I
think that God did
be probably one of my ideal zombie
weapons because it's also long and
ranged in the way and also it's like
using a projectile weapon you'll run out
of ammo eventually you know so there's
that and also like a sword I'm not sure
if a sword would be good you need to
crush with azam azam be really really
sharp sword like a samurai sword that
could like take a head off like a sword
isn't gonna be good if it's just for
stabbing but if you can get like lateral
swipes but like the whole premise of the
zombie now this is getting a little bit
technical but in most things it's
they're not that until their head is
broken in some way right or off or off
so it's like if you can slice off heads
every time with your sword then maybe
it'll be good but like what about just
smashing the head yeah it just seems
like you yeah but what if you if your
knife is if you're sort of super super
super sharp you can do one swipe and get
multiple heads assuming zombies they're
similar height we were two zombies next
to each other no they couldn't do that
to us yeah but I think I think I'm gonna
go for smashing weapon let us know in
the comments below smashing or slashing
[Laughter]
smashing okay so there's this cool
website actually um would you rather
calm it's not actually what are you
rather it's like are rather calm but
it's a bunch of would you rather
questions and you can I guess search by
topic I'm so I pulled up some zombie
once I glanced at a few just to make
sure there were some good ones some are
more lame I'll skip this I thought it'd
be kind of fun to do some zombie would
you rather yeah so the very first thing
it's kind of depressing would you rather
have a zombie apocalypse or have a world
war three now I believe this my vote I
would rather have a zombie apocalypse
then World War three really yes I
I was thinking World War three just cuz
I feel like zombie apocalypse is an
apocalypse so so the main thing I think
though is World War three now that
there's new
their weapons and everyone has them
World War three could be like the end
and and also World War three it'd be
like humans divided which is just sad to
me but a zombie apocalypse would bring
humans together with a common enemy and
I think that like after a zombie
apocalypse we could be stronger and
after World War three it would just be
like and complete just know so I guess
like assuming that we could survive the
apocalypse oh we can survive the
apocalypse
it's very rare they find a cure in Texas
would survive a zombie apocalypse I feel
like there's a good chance I feel yeah
just because like you know humans are
really got-dang smart and zombies are
never that smart not always like kind of
like not I'm not I'm just like waggling
my finger for those of you just
listening I'm like I have a problem with
zombie movies the the zombie movies that
like ignore governments and militaries
and you know stuff like that I think
they like that do more than they do in
the movies World War Z had a pretty good
balance is a really good movie yeah it's
hard cuz I feel like a lot of zombie
movies or like zombie movies or games or
whatever drop you in when it's already
like mid apocalypse yeah yeah and so
it's hard to know like at that point
yeah it's gonna be hard for the
government to get a handle on things
they have depleted resources also but
it's like in the beginning yeah how
preventable is it yeah I think that'd be
more preventable than it is because like
think about how fast they snap like you
know when somebody gets like the measles
or something yeah they're like okay
quarantined immediately yeah yeah I mean
I think that would would be more
resistant than people think to a zombie
apocalypse that's a good point that's my
take though I like your hope okay next
question this is kind of similar
would you rather try to survive a zombie
outbreak or a computer uprising I think
okay you go first on this one
so I like in some ways like I think
would be easier to survive zombies than
a computer uprising because again like
you said zombies are dumb humans are
smart yeah but in a computer uprising we
could also maybe reason with the
computers hmm ok so just for context
like the the images being shown are
zombie outbreak it's the zombies
computer uprising its terminator so I
think that like the whole premise for
this question has to be clarified in
some way cuz like in what year is the
computer operating happening right now
and like Google home is just like
yelling at me like you guys are using
technology or I don't know like like
respect computers it's like and there's
like unlocking and locking your doors
and like turning on valve RAC
ok come on now calm down calm down Alexa
you know but like if in the future
robots like have access to stealth
replication and advanced AI and all of
that that's a heck of a lot more scary
than zombies for some reason yeah I
think I think the question is assuming
the other the ladder the ladder yeah so
I'd say zombies again their computers
were just like completely crippled assal
so though one of the whole reasons why I
compete like humans could survive a
zombie outbreak I believe is because of
computers and you know cell phones and
you know satellites and computer
technology and everything that's like
one of the huge advantages we have where
as if like if there's a computer
uprising we wouldn't be able to take
advantage of any of that but have no
communication would have like radio that
would be completely open to all
computers because there's no way we can
come up with a more advanced encryption
than they can would be like sending
doves around like messenger pigeons and
like back in the medieval days and then
our whole society would break down I
take away the internet computers
technology and like civilization would
stop we wouldn't have any food we
wouldn't have any like how many food
it's just like I'd just be like people
who know how to farm in Homestead that
have any chances
driving for a small period of time you
know but like humans are no longer self
efficient we've specialized too much
yeah that's true I do like your your
concept of the like current times our
Google does yell at us sometimes the
other day I tried talking to him or
Google and she didn't even respond and I
was very upset yes yeah it was quiet you
were speaking directly to her
I spoke clearly the heck she ignored me
yeah she's already getting a little up I
see yep all right so Kailyn quick
question do you think you're prepared
for the zombie apocalypse no that's
great would you rather are you prepared
yes or no would you rather I'm pretty
sure these are like normal person
submitted yes I do like this one because
like okay so the nope picture is like a
bite the yes picture is a house
surrounded by zombies backwards yeah
they just keep walking that's good I
think that like the house that just gets
around and then they start piling on
each other well yes but you know the
humor is pretty good it's good okay so
what do you think we need to do to
prepare for the zombie apocalypse
um underground bunker underground bunker
would be good yeah I think the main
thing that we needed are just supplies
we just need a whole bunch of water a
whole bunch of food and that's pretty
much it I think you need like a barrier
a barrier yeah you know so that barrier
is either you're underground or you have
like a really make wall around you or
you have like a like steel reinforced
exterior okay
okay quick question I think the best not
it's not a question there's a statement
I think the best defense would be like
oceans you know just like sell out sell
out oh do you think they can just walk
underground but would they be smart
enough to like hold a stone so that they
can walk underwater no right cause like
think yeah because they don't have like
air in their lungs uh-oh I guess they
would they were distinct did is think
but they still might not be able to like
make it to you they might get eaten by a
shark or something on the way it depends
on how far out zombie sharks whatever
shark ate a zombie they needs Amba
sharks a shark
yeah yeah it's just like Game of Thrones
except instead of dragons sharks yes the
question is we're not prepared for the
zombie apocalypse I don't like but I do
like your idea of an island cuz the
island will be nice you'd have space to
like grow your own crops mm-hmm you know
I just think it's not everyone can just
like have an island no you know but like
you could probably figure out a way to
dig a bunker yeah but like then you'd be
stuck there forever right or until it
dies down yeah well you'd have a bunker
and then like you'd have like a tunnel
system and then you can fly your drone
up from like a remote tunnel system
check out the area around you you know
we'd have to have solar panels so we
could charge everything yeah yeah yeah
we'd have to have Jones would be great
during the zombie apocalypse yeah yeah
they could observe and distract yeah
observe and distract yeah yeah yeah pull
all the zombies away and then you can
maybe make some like really secure like
drone landing spots so that you could
like land the drone there far away all
the zombies would go there they couldn't
climb the pole yeah you could have like
a like a big pole that was actually like
a open tunnel on top yeah yeah and then
you could land it down through the top
yeah that'd be cool that would be cool
okay so we need excavators yeah solar
panels supplies some way to like make
food without sunlight but I need to like
move someplace where like crops can grow
there are too many swamp crops here so
we need to move somewhere like you know
north I guess right okay so if there is
a zombie apocalypse what do you rather
use an m16 which is a machine gun or a
crossbow I mean I feel like you would
take out more with the m6
tene because it has more ammunition like
you can't carry as many crossbow bullets
as gun bullets it buyers faster but also
you can't retrieve and reuse those
bullets a but you can't retrieve and
reuse so it kind of depends on the
situation if you're like sniping them
one by one
crossbow then you retreat if it's low
volume crossbow but if you're in a
high-volume scenario I think you need
yeah but what if you could only have one
I'd say crossbow yeah I mean I'm being
optimistic thinking I'm not gonna get
attacked by a horde yeah I mean if
you're in a horde I mean you're kind of
done for anyway I think you might be
done for anyway yeah you know I don't
know you just have a whole bunch of
awesome people with crossbows around you
better which is the better place to take
refuge in a zombie apocalypse a mall or
an airport a mall because they have why
because there are it's designed so
there's lots of different ways to get to
different places you know so there's
more paths in the airport there aren't
as many like secret sneaky paths or
maybe there are like where the employees
go
I feel like in the airport we still
might have like some security in place
that might like hinder you somewhat or
maybe the security would be beneficial
because it would keep something out yeah
that's what I think I bet there's more
spaces in an airport that are like
secured and like there's I feel like the
like guards and stuff at airports are
probably trained for higher stakes
scenarios then like mall cops probably
yeah well but at the mall there's
probably more like you know makeshift
weapons you could make at them all from
the stuff in the mall there might be a
sports goods store you could get pick up
a crossbow I've never seen a sports
goods store Adam there's totally one at
our mall no it's not there's a sporting
goods store attached to our malls taxes
new yeah
well if you have a sporting goods store
yeah maybe you can get some weapons but
I don't know I feel like also at an
airport I feel like there's like a
chance of escaping the airport oh yeah
in a plane like we know how to fly in
flame no not us doing it but like if
you're trapped at the airport you're
trapped I'm assuming with other people
at an airport okay so let's say that
like you're adding the airport and the
zombie apocalypse strikes and you know
like people are like the airport people
are like okay we're gonna evacuate
everyone everyone go to the plane that
you want to like leave in to go to that
destination and and there are a whole
bunch of destinations and we can go
anywhere in the world somehow magically
where would you go
Hawaii Oh Island but still in America so
I have to like because I probably don't
have my passport or would you go to like
no yeah you have to go this place that
you can like live Hawaii yeah I was
thinking like a place with low
population you know because like the the
smaller the population is the last
zombie is they'll be there right yeah
but I also feel like some place like
Hawaii is isolated already hmm you know
like unless it the virus has already
spread yeah cause like people are
traveling all over the place it'll
probably be everywhere all at once I
don't think so no no I definitely think
that there'd be it I think by the time
it I mean like there's a chance it'll
hop continents it'll hop but I don't
know if it would be like immediate
mmm-hmm yeah where would you go I'm
trying to figure that out I'm thinking
like this sounds dumb but like Siberia
or someplace like called
cold yeah but like I don't know I feel
like the people in Siberia could like
take care of themselves
probably not we're probably used to that
I mean I feel like I'd rather be in like
but also it's like okay but I think
thing about this can can Dom bees who
still have to like you know okay let's
let's say that they can keep on living
by eating flesh and there's they can
ignore pain and everything like that but
can they survive the cold because if
like cold like the place
you're out it's cold enough to freeze a
human if you're out there when there's
on we just freeze they would freeze well
give you like put a steak outside it
would freeze it freeze that's a pretty
good point actually
Yami's are bundled up yeah but they're
probably not gonna be but if a zombie
bites someone who's already but it would
have to get to them without freezing
yeah still not likely still not likely
okay so move move move north okay in
real life would you rather be in the
walking dead or Jurassic Park
um I would rather be in Jurassic Park
same I feel like we do we ask each other
something similar we're like it was like
Jurassic Park or something else and we
both chose Jurassic Park yeah other
words it sounds cool but also I mean if
you think about this what do you rather
be in real life like both like both
would be worldwide a worldwide dinosaurs
like how could like there all of a
sudden be worldwide dinosaurs that's not
the question that you need to ask you
just have to assume there are and then
answer
Jurassic Park still cause a zombie
apocalypse like The Walking Dead they
make more zombies as they go so it's
like an infection that spreads whereas
slowly flow naturally and stop I think
that like I don't know I think humans
could totally take out the dinosaurs
yeah dinosaurs are less scary to me way
less scary bigger yeah I feel like it's
easier to control that population yeah I
think so too
so Jurassic Park the zombie apocalypse
is here what defense tactic will you
employ one is our mounted all-metal
anti-zombie spear with mounted pistol
which is like a spear and a pistol
mounted to your arm the other is
swinging a deer carcass around as a
weapon and there's an illustration this
is wonderful it's wonderful I'm so
confused
but I'm I'll choose the arm-mounted
all-metal anti-zombie spear with mounted
pistol of course you know what if what
if you could swing the deer carcass but
mount the arm mounted all-metal
anti-zombie spear was not a pistol like
to the deer that would be pretty
impressive yeah okay also like to the
antlers there's there's like limbs
antlers I'm gonna read this as its
stated on the website woody rather a
zombie apocalypse aliens to come I mean
that's that's that's that's a hard
question ask it's like are the aliens
family are they bad how advanced are
they I mean I think that if they've been
able to travel through the cosmos really
I'm on earth they're pretty advanced so
I think yeah I mean I'm gonna assume
that the aliens are bad since they're
being compared to a zombie apocalypse if
they are bad I think we can take on the
zombies more than an advanced alien race
oh yeah yeah you know it's kind of like
the supercomputer question again
yeah but there is a chance that they are
good and they are simply exploring and
want to make contact in which case that
could maybe lead to good things I don't
really I don't foresee it leading the
good thing I don't think we're gonna be
like oh hey neighbor from another galaxy
what up great to meet you you stay over
there and we'll stay over here Kay bye
alright I'm now nominate Caitlyn to make
first contact would you rather have a
girlfriend slash boyfriend that is a
zombie or have a girlfriend slash
boyfriend that is a werewolf permanently
weight permanently like there always and
before always in wolf form like the
werewolf is alive so you kind of have to
choose that right cuz ami would just be
like want to eat you and stink horribly
yeah I mean the werewolf probably wants
to eat you too but maybe because they're
alive there's still like some humanity I
like where
they didn't say like a mad werewolf some
werewolves retain their like human minds
women werewolf form depends on the lure
that you're following you know that's
true yeah so it could it's like Beauty
and the Beast yeah so I think that's
yeah I mean I love you I'm glad we're
married but you know if I had to choose
well I would be the Beast oh yeah gosh
[Laughter]
so Kailyn do you have a favorite zombie
game I like um The Last of Us Wow a lot
we are saying it like amazing but you
know what else I like plants vs. zombies
I really like plants oh good great game
I think I have sunk a lot of hours into
that yeah I did too
probably too many yeah and in the first
and the second person Resident Evil
though ooh
that game was good so I didn't I liked
played a little bit with you yeah but I
didn't really play it very much
well like but it's not so interesting
because so many of the Resident Evil
games they vary so much depending on
which one you played yeah they vary a
lot there's so many of them there's so
many of them but I remember one for the
we was just so good because I actually
really did like the way they implemented
the gun you can move around you can aim
with a gun and it was actually super fun
it's remastered and everything it was
just it was one of the best uses of the
Wii that I've seen a game do you know
what I mean good like the Wii looks like
a little bit gimmicky and sometimes
malfunctioning sometimes infuriating
yeah like when you were playing the
Skyward Sword and then like zombie
movies you asked me this in the video
but Shaun of the Dead is my favorite
zombie movie yeah there's there's a
decent amount of good ones I also really
like okay I can't believe you haven't
seen World War Z cuz that was like
really good I also actually I have a few
more favorite zombie movies and I'm
realizing they're like kind of
they're not like tip none of them are
typical horror zombie movies I just
looked it up in World War Z didn't get
the best rating I think some good
memories of it I don't know so um so my
other favorite zombie movies warm bodies
Oh warm bodies was good so good which is
like if you guys kind of haven't seen it
it's like a Romeo and Juliet but zombie
edition yeah it sounds corny and it is
why the concept is a little bit you and
Juliet it's like the concept for so many
movies mmm yeah that's true if you think
about it it was really well done it was
so good it's so good I also really liked
a zombie land I mean still a zombie land
was so good I'm catching I'm like you
don't bat it memory yes I probably
shouldn't bother to ask you what your
favorites are they start of the dead
warm bodies and Zombieland I think it's
all me land might be one my favorites
really good and poor Bill Murray if you
haven't watched it yet I'd say just
watch it yeah a new zombie land coming
out I'm excited I um that I was able to
get more into Walking Dead I think it
has dragged on for too long for some
reason I think so too like um we got to
the part where they were all on the farm
and it started just kind of focusing on
like love interest and stuff and I was
like really no zombies have showed up
yet like you guys are just hanging out
of the farms on each other Tom B's show
up real big real bad I believe and they
go back into crazy thing and then
there's more you know settlements and
everything and more drama but I just
stopped caring some I don't know but I
it was one I like wanted to watch yeah I
don't know sometimes I've shows like
that where it's like everybody loves it
yeah I'm like you'd like the concept
yeah but you can't get into it well you
know guys if you if you really love
zombies and you want to like rank your
best movies games all
that you can make a website with
Squarespace is the sponsor of today's
episode and they're great if you want to
make a website for anything you can buy
your domain there you can set up your
hosting there there's a whole bunch of a
professional templates and if anything
goes wrong they have 24/7 support and
you can I bet that they would even have
24/7 support during the zombie
apocalypse because they're that good
they're that good yep and if you want to
hear more and see more Kaitlyn has the
URL because I forgot it okay so free
free trial go to Squarespace calm and to
get 10% off your first purchase go to
Squarespace calm slash Evan and Kaitlyn
podcast and use evident podcast as your
code Evan and Kaitlyn podcast for 10%
off thanks guys that was dope you like
we're sneaky sneaky sneaky I'm
definitely inspired by Jenna and Julian
a little bit you know yeah all right
well I think that we're out of like
zombie theoretical should we go into
what we're digging
all right my thing of the week is
discord I don't know what it is but I
love it it's kind of a chatroom and
there's a whole bunch of different like
channels and you can chat about like
general interests or we have a basically
it's like a chatroom for our fans for
them all to hang out and like talk about
their shared interests help each other
out I love that it's like a really nice
wholesome place right now and we're
gonna keep it that way
yes it's very cute we're making like all
sorts of emojis and custom things over
there and it's just fun
whoo I started a polls tab where I can
get feedback on like I got titles and
thumbnails and one thing that I really
like okay guys there's a hot take on
polls I just love being able to put a
whole bunch of options out there and
have people vote yes or no for all
options it's like a multiple choice
where people can select multiple things
but also if they are like opposed to
something they can also vote that which
is really important to us it's a
valuable piece of feedback and you don't
get that on any other poll maybe I just
I'm not a poll like master I don't know
all of the places and different types of
polls you can do so let me know if the
poll out there if there is a poll out
there that does that I mean there may be
you'd ever seen it I've never seen one
that's like integrated into a social
platform yeah there's like the Twitter
polls and there's the Instagram polls
but also like Twitter polls you can only
do four options I think you can't do
pictures for each and we we like we add
like eight titles and six thumbnails and
we wanted to vote the votes to be
attached to those thumbnails an
interesting thing is like because you
mentioned the ability to down vote yeah
pull items so like there were two
thumbnails I had an equal amount of up
votes but one of them had twice as many
down votes and if we hadn't been able
see the down post we would have looked
at those as equal Reinke they're
completely not equal because the same
amount of people liked them but twice as
many people disliked one and another one
got like no dislikes it's just like very
interesting it's so interesting and I
just it just blew my mind that polls
don't
that ability yeah we'll put a link to
our discord in the description slash
show notes you guys can check it out and
who knows what's coming next predict
this graph and who knows what's coming
next like in terms of features and
channels and everything we're continuing
to build it up yeah ok so my thing of
the week is a game we started streaming
called little nightmares and it's like
it's Kalin's perfect game all the
elements that you want for this week cuz
it's like a horror game that's also a
puzzle game um so it kind of reminds me
of like similar vibes of like limbo and
inside I don't know if you're familiar
with those those two games but it's it's
very dark and eerie and creepy but
you're solving puzzles it's not like a
like horror survival game you know which
is slightly higher stress yeah but
there's it was also platforming and like
there's there's so much going on in that
game the only thing that gets me is like
it's like the camera is a little bit
wobbly cuz you're on a ship or something
which gives me a tiny bit motion
sickness well like it's totally worth
playing it it just kind of feels like a
ship we're still like figuring out the
story yeah I mean there's so many like
moments where I just like freaked out
though like we were like during the
stream
so much yeah it was really fun to stream
like a scary game though yeah it was
yeah so by the time that you guys are
hearing this the highlight won't be out
yet will link to the full archive of the
stream but um coming soon to Evan and
Caitlin gaming youtube.com slash Evan
and Caitlin gaming we'll have a
highlight of that yeah this is a little
bit of a shorter podcast but I think
we're gonna be experimenting with doing
some of those every now and then well
we'll continue to do topics will
continue to do games will continue to do
all the things a game and a topic rolled
into one
yeah yeah but just like still
experimenting with the the format and
everything and keeping things
sustainable because we would rather
continue to do one podcast a week as of
taking a week break just because we're
too busy but like these shorter ones are
a little bit faster for us yeah and it's
only ten minutes shorter than normal
yeah we're working there we're working
we're figuring it out alright guys
thanks so much for joining appreciate
all of the reviews that we've seen
coming in we read every single one and
make it happy and share this for the
fence because yeah
get these bye
[Music]